but i have to dash down tell me that no
i just forgot to tell you that yeah
what happens when two black holes
collide you get a bigger black hole
you get a
big black hole is one possibility which
um i think
the the mass depending it depends on
what the black holes are doing i think i
believe
it's never been observed um
it's
it's thought to happen so since every
galaxy has a black hole in the middle of
it and we know that one of the ways you
get bigger galaxies is by merging
galaxies together then presumably the
galaxies merge together their black
holes then spiral into the center and
they end up merging to form a bigger
black hole so probably whenever two
galaxies merge you end up ultimately
merging two black holes together if they
come together relatively slowly then
they can sort of merge together and
you'll create a big black hole that's
got a mass which is actually less than
the sum of the two masses because it
releases energy
we've never seen it directly there are
actually experiments underway now to try
and detect it because one of the things
that happens is when two black holes are
in that kind of final phase of spiraling
in together they actually end up giving
away a lot of their energy as things
called gravitational waves so if you
have a gravitational wave detector one
of the strong signals that those
gravitational wave detectors are likely
to detect is the inspiring of black
holes just as they've
merged together to form a bigger black
hole so
within the next 20 or 30 years hopefully
this is something that we will witness
directly
but many black holes are spinning and
some of them the supermassive black
holes in the in the centers of galaxies
are spinning really really quickly so
um i've heard of some simulations which
are you know modeling galaxies colliding
and then of course they've got these
supermassive black holes millions of
times the mass of the sun is hundreds of
millions of times with some of them
spinning really rapidly and
the the simulations suggest that
actually what what can happen is that
this they're both spinning and it's like
spinning tops coming and they can
actually bang together and one can be
bounced out
just totally out of the system
altogether leaving you with this big one
so they don't it doesn't look like they
always merge and often they can go out
so i think it depends on what's actually
happening to the black holes themselves
as to what the
the fate of it will be so one of the
amazing things about this is if one of
these pairs of massive black holes
merges together anywhere in the in the
universe pretty much then the kind of
detectors they're building now will
actually be able to detect it so we'll
be able to see this phenomenon right
across the universe so even if it only
happens very rarely if it happens
anywhere in the universe we'll actually
see it happening are you someone who can
discuss and enjoy the beauty of a sunset
or are you someone who'll take all that
time thinking about the atmospheric
effect on sun rays and things like that
i'm thinking about the science behind it
but that's making me enjoy it even more
um the universe is a pretty amazing
place and it's even more amazing when
you understand what's going on or a bit
of what's going on behind it
oh you you would you of course you would
join but you enjoy them all i spend all
my time looking at this elusive green
flash i
every time i see a sunset with a distant
horizon i always look and some people
who i respect tell me that it's there
it's some kind of visual optical optical
effect uh perhaps in our eyes rather or
the way our brain processes light but
i've i've always looked for this and
i've never found it but of course every
of course scientists like real sunsets
and sunsets in the paintings of claude
lorraine tremendous yeah
perhaps chlorine sunsets are even better
than natural ones
we just had
just been on holiday to south
west of france and we were in a really
rural place with some friends who came
out and just said asked me to come
outside one evening with them and
and uh there was the milky way i mean
the the the real milky way right the one
where you see the band going straight
across the sky
unfortunately even though we live in
a fairly rural place here there's still
obviously too much light to spot that
but this was just a band of light going
across
and it i didn't spend my time thinking
well how many can i see how many stars
are in there and how are those stars
forming i just thought
wow that's bloody amazing man
it was really neat
i don't think that explaining the
details of how it works takes away from
its beauty at all
so they're completely continuous now i
will look at the sunset and take
photographs of it and say how beautiful
it is and my wife will drag me to see
the moonlight and everything like that
and you can enjoy it
i guess
i i would flatter myself to say that i
can do both at once
that actually that you know this because
people kind of think well you know when
you understand the science of something
that takes somehow detracts from the
beauty of it i don't think it does i can
you know both
i appreciate the beauty of a rainbow say
and actually enjoy the fact that i
understand why it's there and i don't
think there's really any any paradox any
contradiction between doing both at the
same time i think
one of the things that feynman says and
which is i think so true one of the
perhaps advantages that
people like myself who work in this area
have is that
not only can i love the beauty of it for
for its own sake
but then i can actually begin to think
about the the beauty of the mathematics
that describes it and so there's an
additional beauty if you like which adds
onto it it doesn't take away from the
from the beauty you know again coming
back to feynman you know the fact that
you look at that sunset and you you
think about well how is the light
scattered and and and how the physics of
that doesn't diminish from the beauty of
that sunset in fact it increases the the
beauty of that sunset is that what you
say to your wife when she says do you
think i'm beautiful uh um and if you
perhaps wouldn't put it in those terms
no but that's another thing you know i
i've you know
my wife my children i loved love dearly
love to you know to use that that that
cliche with all my heart and soul but
the fact you know that you can also
consider love and emotions or think
about love and emotions philosophically
in terms of biochemical pathways or
whatever it doesn't diminish that love
so i mean you might understand where the
moonlight is coming from and where all
the different patterns in the sky are
coming from and you get a certain joy
from understanding where a rainbow comes
from or any of these other things but
the ascetic sense the sense that the
world is a beautiful place to live in
the rest of the universe is hostile but
the earth is wonderful and it ought to
be preserved and and you see nature and
dragonflies and all sorts of other
things in in your garden that's just
wonderful but that must be true of
everybody surely i see the same sunsets
and rainbows as everybody else